hey gang it's your old pals uncle hank
and kippy just want to thank you for
tuning in to ru garbage
yeah guys make sure you subscribe that
way you get the episode as they come out
you can also go to gasdigitalnetwork.com
use promo code ayg
to get bonus content and get the
episodes before they come out and hd
streaming
do it yeah welcome to another exciting
edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley i feel like i'm at a [ __ ]
deposition right now
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is
are you garbage the show where we sit
down with your favorite comedians and
find out they go up classy
or if they're a huge [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] i gotta tell you on this show
i'm leaning towards the ladder
i'm your host h foley coming at you on a
beautiful day our first live show here
at the punchline philly
philly makes some [ __ ] noise tonight
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me
he is the brains behind the operation he
put this whole thing together also set
the ticket prices so if you're upset
but the next time you reach for a best
pal gang do yourself a favor
and make it a kippy give it up for kevin
james ryan hey what's up everybody
thanks for coming out
i already got a text from my friend what
clan rally did you invite me to so
happy to be here
[Laughter]
man i can hear the n-words flying by
flying down 95.
uh guys thanks so much for coming out
this is [ __ ] awesome i appreciate it
thank you
yes sir we have a very special guest
here with us today as comedian
co-counsel
on the podcast uh you've seen him on our
episode of course from matt and shane's
secret podcast give it up
for the young bull shane gillis
everybody hey
hey hey how are you
[Laughter]
turning to hugh hefner you might
recognize him from snl for nine minutes
ladies and gentlemen
shane gillis this guy makes getting
cancelled in art form ladies and
gentlemen
i'm gonna do it again i will get i
promise you i will get cancelled again
we don't doubt it dude we do not without
i heard mad tv's coming back so you got
an opportunity coming up there
but gang our very special guest that we
have on the podcast today
we want to thank him from taking a break
from guarding the the frank rizzo statue
ladies and gentlemen give it the [ __ ] up
for philadelphia's own
mike rainey everybody
buddy this is your time to shine we uh
we're gonna play a little game called
are you garbage before we do
just do me a favor so kippy and i can
kind of get an idea
uh we were talking in the back shane
says that we're going to
be completely surprised that you're
complete class
you uh you play the violin you like to
paint sculpt and write poetry
i'm kidding he said you were a coked up
[ __ ] dirt bag
but what is because because you don't
know that uh when
when like kevin chris cotton tom cassie
and i we started out in comedy
rainey was kind of already on the scene
but we always stayed real
[ __ ] clear of him he wore a lot of
[ __ ] sweatsuits yeah
this guy would show up to [ __ ] open
mics dressed like [ __ ] dj khaled
[Laughter]
and you always had that look on your
face like you wanted to knock me the
[ __ ] out for some reason
so i always stay clear but what is your
back story where did you grow up tell us
the deal
um you know what guys i could probably
save you the next
they already paid drag it out a little
bit create the mystery the next 59
minutes of this podcast by letting you
know
that i have driven drunk with my kids in
the car
his kids are here tonight in the back
everybody give a nice round of applause
we're all wearing helmets if anybody
recognizes
jesus they wrote in the back of a pickup
truck
where did you grow up are you a philly
kid i grew up in upper derby
pennsylvania
yikes yikes yeah the perk capital of
pennsylvania
shout out to upper darby yep so i grew
up there we moved out when my sister got
shot in 94.
really yes it was her fault wait did you
say got her shot like star search or
something like that yeah
or actually got shot no she actually
yeah she got shot did she live
yeah holy [ __ ] tough tough broad i'll
tell you that
what did she get shot where'd she get
shot what'd she get shot for uh just two
kids robbed her um
she was coming from the 69th street
terminal and two kids robbed her
she gave him her money and they shot her
anyway
damn hey criminals in philly they're
[ __ ] committed
they don't play dude well they weren't
too committed because she's a real pile
of [ __ ] and she survived
so they weren't committed enough
and where did you live in philly when
that happened i lived in upper darby and
it was like uh maybe like two blocks
from like the west philly border
okay so that's what real scumbag is like
no it's upper darby by 25 feet but you
know
so funny your [ __ ] sister got shot
yeah that's all
who the [ __ ] has a sister that got shot
about who has the video well she
there's another interesting aspect of
her getting shot so she had been with
her boyfriend at the time for about four
weeks
and i didn't realize we were this close
but apparently we got close as she be
as she was on the mend from getting shot
where'd they shoot her uh in the abdomen
ooh
gut shot that's the worst so she was uh
for the listener fully takes cannonballs
every saturday
yeah if anybody's got a 20 bucks it'll
meet your house this is
this is not great to add but um
no no i was watching starship troopers
this afternoon
and at one point this guy gets his legs
ripped off and he looks at the main
character he's like you know what to do
to like finish him off
he just shoots him in the stomach that
guy's like
they leave yeah she was probably the
first person to just get shot in the
stomach since [ __ ] oswald
nobody ever [ __ ] done that picture
she got the jack ruby she's like yeah
you already got my 20 bucks
the [ __ ] dude you shot me yeah just some
60 year old kid from west philly dressed
in an old white suit and wait for to her
[Laughter]
no but she had she had been with her
boyfriend for about four weeks at the
time
and for some reason she uh she gave me
this information that
they consummated their relationship
while she was on the mend
um but they didn't consummate it the
typical way uh she let hanal
yes what what because she was on her
period at the time so it was just
that was god shooting her so she was
just a [ __ ] bloodbath in every sense
of the word
he put his dick in the hole was in the
hospital and got
[ __ ] when she got home she got
home
who gets shot and go does anal what the
[ __ ]
that's like at least a bottle of wine or
something getting in the mood a chick
that does that after he after she after
you let him put it on your butt you're
like put it in the gunshot
how did she why did she tell you that i
don't know well i would i would like
well i was worried about my sister so i
would spend a lot of time talking to her
and i learned that
how did this but yeah you worried about
it but then like so uh you [ __ ] these
days or what's going on
uh well i grew up in a very strange
household look
yeah what are you doing he knows i
wasn't going to give him because i
wanted to see you two do your job
yeah because you're good at it you get
this trash out
this is where things get weird when you
start talking about coming
what's up what's the household like
we're growing up in
minus the gun shots uh very
unfortunately very sex positive
what you're up to one of those weird sex
cults where everybody's [ __ ]
everybody i wasn't i barely speak to my
family now so i'm like the normal one
that's not saying much yeah so i was
like no i'm doing pretty good now you
know i
did a gunshot i got my i got my head on
straight to give you an indication as to
how [ __ ] things were
my sister's bedroom was next to mine and
this guy that she led [ __ ] her was a
manager at risque video
and i know i'm familiar i would
regularly hear my father as he was going
to work at the firehouse at 6 30 in the
morning knock on her door and say you
got any tapes
what oh my god what kind of cheap
bastard goes to his daughter for tapes
how do you know he wasn't just looking
for like uh home alone or something like
that
we didn't have any [ __ ] uh any uh
booby traps around the house
so so yeah that'll brighten this crowd
up
knowing about how it was done what did
your parents do for a living
for a while my dad was a fireman and
then he was a cab driver
define a while and why was it a while
and what happened
what was that what was the dramatic end
to that there was never an answer but
what black family's house did he refuse
to put the fire at on
that got him fired by the philadelphia
police department
we actually lived like eight blocks from
where move was he he was in the
helicopter he was actually a deep cut by
gillis
[Laughter]
holy sh and did you say then you moved
from somewhere or you were always in the
house in upper darby we
we moved we were in upper derby from
like 83 to 94.
we moved after my sister got shot
because the neighborhood the
neighborhood was turning that's gonna be
the name of her memoir
[Laughter]
after my sister got shot the mike rainey
story
tonight on nbc and where did you move to
after that
lansdowne lansdowne yeah which i don't
even know where that is a little fancier
not lansdale not dale but down wow like
shane has
definitely ain't nothing that sounds
like a [ __ ] landsdale to me
speaking of which i love a little bit of
lands downs if you know what i mean
it's like landsdale but doesn't speak
very well kev i meant to tell you you
look like johnny cash's [ __ ] son
georgie
i hurt myself eating spaghettios
a ring of spire it is my own funeral
maybe i am wearing black
all right so you guys moved i shot my
grainy
just sister watch her die
[Laughter]
[Music]
keep it on rainy will we
[Laughter]
so you move that to lansdowne and your
mom and dad are together i understand
yeah they're still together
okay and what did your mom do for a
living she was
a cleaning lady for a while and then she
became
the secretary of my high school so at
one point everyone's under qualified but
okay
fair enough hold on a sec white cleaning
lady
she broke the mold dude got into the
rackets real quick i like it
but she became the secretary of my high
school and at one point
my dad my mom and my sister all worked
at my high school
wow holy [ __ ] was your sister in high
school when she worked there
no she's graduating she was doing a work
release program at high school
but i'll tell you what her texas tommies
were [ __ ] fantastic
all right and then trying to think of
what other information we need before we
can start playing again
the sister shot at 94. i think we're
[ __ ] set let's find out if he drank
milk with dinner
what the [ __ ] are we doing here all
right gang let's play a little [ __ ]
ru garbage with mike rainey give me a
nice big round of applause
all right so a couple of the standard
questions we like to ask uh here on the
podcast number one we'll start out
what was the name of the street that you
grew up on it could be your your
lansdowne street or your upper darby
street
it actually sounds very dignified it was
wellington road
beef wellington i like it roads are i
don't know if that sounds too dig
that shows how much garbage you are
you're like no it was actually pretty
classy it was uh
wellington throughway it was pretty good
no wellington's all right i'll give him
that wellington's not bad yeah what
street did you grow up on
me east meadow
[Music]
drive east meadow drive ah that's
actually yeah
i'm nice i come from nice you know
time magazine you said your dad
would you say time magazine doesn't
think so
weren't you on cnn's worst people of the
year list i was i'm from east meadow
it's pretty nice if you open up time
magazine it's like racist
despite growing up on east meadow road
race is shane gillis
yep and what was the name of the grocery
store
that your mother went to or she was just
stealing food from the high school what
was the deal
yeah we went to iga well what the the
international grocers association
that might i think that's what it is
isn't that a money management company
sounds like a check cashing place yeah
that's me
well it would have fit right in with our
financials
did you ever catch your do you ever cash
your check in a supermarket because i
have for sure done that oh
dude my mom used to pay groceries with a
[ __ ] check
dated two weeks before or after the
[ __ ] the groceries went bad foley's
the only person who had travelers check
from the county next door
the biggest check i ever got i cashed at
a check cashing price
they crushed you on the fees by the way
they did it was for five grand my aunt
had died and she left me five grand and
i got it on a friday
dude that is garbage she got shots
she got shot getting off the train son
of a [ __ ] came back to finish it
opened the casket to get her checkbook
[Laughter]
that she
left you yeah dude cashing a five
thousand dollar inheritance check at
a [ __ ] check cashing place yeah what
was it an all-time
garbage move what was the fee on that
you had to lose at least a grand on the
topic i think it was 800 bucks
more what you guys are missing here is
why what were you up to
yeah what were you doing what do you do
it's his money and he needs it now all
right
[ __ ] jg what stop asking questions
give me the screen it's my dead
grandmother's money and i want it now
this one this was uh why enough why on a
friday night you couldn't wait till
monday till the banks open
i had never had more than 80 dollars
to my name up until that point i don't
know
by the way foley's bully's main banking
institution
is a check cashing place in the lower
east side just so everybody knows shout
out to lewis
he's he's got one of those like see cash
10 checks here we'll give you a free one
card in his wallet well for a while i
actually had
like almost like a credit card like it
was like a bank card
from quick checks up at uh in astoria in
queens
where you know like it takes sometimes
if it's like an out-of-state
check they won't take it listen to the
explanation of this dirt bag [ __ ]
well you know sometimes when you're
jammed up and the three-day you don't
have three business days you know
yeah i can't but coke dealers don't wait
three days to get their money
they want it now but they gave you a
card
once you passed the screening process
which was if you had a [ __ ] pulse
they would give you the card so you can
get the money instantly
did you have a similar situation no dude
i uh i went in on a friday i think they
closed at eight this was like 6
30. so i ran in there it was united
check cashing on marshall road
that came out and i kicked my heels up
because i now had 4 200
to my name we're in the money i was not
in the drugs yet this was 2001. i did
not get in the drugs until about
2000 and it was the year the eagles went
to the super bowl
2004. what philly trash that's a that's
like pc and
after death well it's before the super
bowl so
it was the year the sixers traded elton
brand it was a good year
so i i got 4 200 on a friday night i got
a sega dreamcast
i bought my wife a kitten and i took my
boy steve to vegas
in that order yeah a dream cast
did that come out in like 93 man
i had no idea what was what it looked
cool so i bought it now you you were a
troop also
yeah yeah dude you're using troops dude
yeah you were in the service
oh you were i was but then i stopped
going
[Laughter]
i wasn't aware that was an option you
can do it if you're in the marine or if
you're in the reserves you can do that
um i i feel like i've set the trend like
i'm kind of the rosa parks of quitting
the marines
so i signed up in 99 and i lasted until
i stopped going in the summer of 2001
right before 9 11.
it's not [ __ ] summer school how do
you just stop [ __ ] going
it was a dispute over financial aid they
wanted a piece of the five grand i
didn't have money for the book
so what's the point of [ __ ] going
yeah so they weren't going to give me my
financial aid for community college so i
was like all right i'm just not going in
protest
who the [ __ ] needs financial aid for
community college
dude it was like 1200 a semester oh
would you would you buy
uh most boot camp i remember you did
something
well it reminded me of the dreamcast
you're you're bad with money yeah well
i've heard the horrible
only horrible gifts he just spent he's
bought a [ __ ] dreamcast
when he then went to vegas we know he's
bad well i don't know
well when you go to bootcamp camp you
get paid the entire time you're in there
you don't make a lot
but i think you make something like like
400 bucks a week because we're all like
privates or private first class so
we're getting like 400 a week they make
you like pay for uniforms and [ __ ] so
that's deductive but when you get out of
boot camp
they just give you money direct deposit
so i had dude
i probably had like a thousand bucks and
we had 10 days leave
and on the night before i had to go down
to camp lejeune i treated the whole
squad
to olympics getting kid rock tickets oh
my god
and i don't know if you've ever treated
your whole squad to kid rock
but when bob with the box kicks in
dude you're leaning up against the floor
like andy dufresne on the [ __ ] roof
watching your boys drink beers
it could have been one of our own bands
we were sitting here
we almost felt like real men hey mike
you want to get in the pit for bob with
the boss
no you guys do yeah mike rainey just sat
there with a weird smile on his face
watching that [ __ ] sing it was
beautiful
i gave up the pit when i killed my wife
dude that's insane that's one thing
about me when i get money
the whole squad's got money the whole
squad
that people would have your back it's
like rainey's in there he got us a game
gear ghetto
hey man he took us to the oasis let's go
[ __ ] get him
holy [ __ ] jesus
uh do you remember the split you got a
790 dude i was shocked
i got an 870. i can't believe you
[ __ ] beat me well going in
you idiot he beat me in a lower score i
mean oh
i thought foley was so dumb he thought
whatever
the lower the number now you were stuck
he in jesus a genius yeah [ __ ] mensah
over here
what happened dude you're pretty smart i
thought you were autistic this is
shocking
um i also suffered from severe anxiety
in high school so
i was running late on the day of the
s.a.t and my dad drove me
and when he pulled when we pulled up all
the kids were waiting outside
and everybody it seemed like they
stopped their conversation just to look
at me getting dropped off by my dad
so i felt like everybody was talking
about me so i was just crushed by
anxiety heading in
and i just wanted to get done as quickly
as possible but they let they only let
you go at a specific time
but i rushed through it and i got done i
was like can i leave the ladies like no
you got to stay
so but it was good enough to get you in
the community college
well when i got to community college my
math was so they were like who let you
in here
dude my math is so they were putting up
like problems on the board like google
hunting but they were wrong
[Laughter]
like no [ __ ] but dude when i got to
community college like i didn't get to
take a regular math class
they put me in the basement and had me
watch vhs tapes of people teaching math
and i had to wear the gigantic
headphones
he just sat there watching old episodes
of full house everybody else
like he's [ __ ] setting fighter jets
off a [ __ ] aircraft carrier
jesus christ [ __ ] did you finish
community college
what's your degree in i finished two
years ago
i went from 1996 to 2018.
hey are you a doctor
or your van wilder you're the man
like the party man i'm [ __ ] rape van
wilder
no but i got that community college of
2018 and i'm currently enrolled at
school and i should be finished in
december
yeah give it up for mike rainey
everybody dreams do come true
in philadelphia oh clap you got a
[ __ ] 790
kick them out of school get out of
school yeah i think you're who in here
has the highest
s.a.t score anybody huh
yeah i'm looking at a lot of [ __ ]
trolls nobody has
somebody here had to give up i got 11
40. anybody beat 11
40. we got 11 40. i got uh i got 11 70.
11.70 [ __ ] you [ __ ]
who's next what do you got back there in
the back
12 20.
dude this is like an autism auction hey
somebody toss that nerd in a [ __ ]
locker will you
i got a nerd going once going twice
all right i think we got to play the
game here let's do it let's go ahead and
get into this a little yeah we have been
what are you talking about you weirdo
all right the edible's kicking in 25
minutes into the podcast let's get
started will we
what do you got kip um this is this is a
pretty good one
this is definitely philly trash it do
you have any aunts or uncles where you
don't use the real name
example aunt i think you should ask do
you have any that do
use their real name um not only do i
have well
she died last week my aunt my aunt bitty
aunt bitty bitty you'll enjoy this as
well but uh when i was four she used to
make me watch porn with her
what yep
what's she got on her sats is that the
one who gave you five grand
no that was my aunt pat who would who
bought me porn
my aunt pat who gave me the five grand
playboy used to send out these catalogs
where you could buy softcore porn
and when i became of whacking age i used
to stay at my aunt pats all the time and
i think she was aware that i was of
whacking age
so she's like here order one out of this
book and i instantly knew what she meant
so i ordered the chameleon with tory
wells and six weeks later i got the
communion with tori wells
and i was just [ __ ] dude i learned
how to jerk i couldn't even get a book
out of that like book fair
why is everybody all porn in your family
yeah what's that all about no i don't
know
that's a [ __ ] problem that's a very
strange yeah yeah it's
definitely [ __ ] up that's like a real
weird uh she look at it with you
yeah always trial polly's trying to get
in and was she hot what's the deal yeah
not my five grand aunt my [ __ ] creep
aunt
she was the very first one of my
earliest memories
was of being in bed with my creep aunt
we were both naked
and she's making me look at a playgirl
magazine and asking me what i thought of
it
what what yeah can we be broadcasting
we're technically in public right now
can we get gas digital legal in here
lewiston what the [ __ ] like the show is
like are you garbage or classy like well
i've been raped
yeah you know when your aunt touches
your peter
i was sexually assaulted by a family
member that answers your question
asking you what you liked yeah i don't
know like what was your answer
[Laughter]
i love gi joe like i don't know
dude and i'll never forget like in this
like magazine it was a dude who had his
dick in a hot dog bun and he was putting
mustard on it
so yeah pretty funny bully's jumping up
pretty hot to me
yeah so in hindsight yeah you know
pretty much potato roll or just white
bread what are you talking about here
dude on the next page he's got it loaded
up into a hot dog gun
holy [ __ ] she's [ __ ] up man
and you don't talk to your family
anymore do you still see her
she died last week oh [ __ ] did you go to
the funeral no it's today
no what yeah i swear to god dude i'll
show you the pity services are today
yeah they weren't
dead shout out to infinity this one goes
to aunt bitty
old [ __ ] aunt sandusky dude
[Laughter]
she's out yeah i got news for you she
ain't up in heaven i can tell you that
purgatory at best curvature
come on snl please purgatory that's a
good piece of business
i have a very kind heart so i knew she
was down in her luck at one point so i
lent her 300
to keep her electric on damn and she
repaid me when she got paid out from a
slip and fall at acme
[Laughter]
what in the [ __ ] did you grow up with
holy [ __ ]
i feel like i need hand sanitizer it's
just like the fact that you're somebody
getting a marble like a stat what the
[ __ ]
just the lingo of like a yeah you know
slip and fall yeah
that's not the first whiffer in the
rainy household either
all right other than the statutory rape
were you a lunchables kid growing up or
you don't strike me as a capri sun guy
we didn't have lunchables i mean i grew
up in the 80s like we just had like
bologna and liverwurst liverwurst yeah
damn bologna i can see
did anybody out there eat liverwurst
yeah they're under a [ __ ] 95.
i got some on me
holy [ __ ] was at least name brand was
like deets and watson liverwurst or was
it like generic liverpool
the only time we got cool [ __ ] i
remember we got this off what do you
mean you were looking at porn when you
were hot
that's [ __ ] pretty cool [ __ ] yeah
keep the poor zed give me the [ __ ]
playboy you must have been a real
[ __ ] weirdo
in school yeah i wonder why you had
anxiety
i'm i'm actually stunned that i was not
a school shooter
well there's still time
actually at work they have active
shooter drills and they actually want
people somebody to volunteer each time
to do it
and you show up like rambo damn somebody
gets to be the shooter in the active
shooter
you're supposed to just like check knobs
but i'll go in and like [ __ ] rules
yeah that'd be pretty give the shooter
like a paintball gun and really be like
you gotta work on it yeah you know at
the end be like who got hit
all right hey herschewicz you got a
zigzag you can't do it
you're running straight down the hallway
because he's coming for you
he wrote it down he said he was coming
for you every drill the same people get
shot
[Laughter]
well mike has his favorites we can tell
you that
i always thought about that with school
shooting drills it's like when you do
scoring jails the school shooter is in
the school
so he knows what you're going to do i
would say keep the weird kids
out tell them you're doing one thing and
then when it actually happens
everybody goes the other day you gotta
set up some sort of like venus fly trap
for the autistic kids yeah yeah
be like yo there's a magic uh gathering
card game going on in the
cafeteria and then you have the school
shooting talk
listen i'm gonna tell you guys probably
the only funny thing you'll ever hear
about sandy hook
no no jesus christ oh god don't do it
yeah
i got disney checks coming in pull it
back with that will you yeah
uh on the um state of connecticut's
website you can read the entire report
and mochi
most likely who reads that [ __ ]
report dude you are a [ __ ]
can we switch seats and he's been
training dude and he does jiu jitsu
yeah he's the only guy in his 40s who
gets cauliflower he's gonna he's gonna
tap out of kindergarten
he's got there's one aspect of the race
where they're talking about how like the
teachers have gotten the kids
into bathrooms to try to like keep them
away it's like look you got to [ __ ]
keep quiet like it would be like 10 kids
in a bathroom
and in one of the bathrooms one of the
kids kept getting chastised by the
teacher
because he kept accidentally flushing
the toilet ah
was that motion censored no it was just
what are you going to do you know what i
mean i get some privacy in here please
school shootings guys what the [ __ ] i'm
working with what i got here
just so you know none of my granny's
comments are anyway associated with ru
garbage or the gas digital network or mr
lewis
trying to get signed by [ __ ] barstool
jesus christ come on barcelona
come on all right let's switch gears
what about the holidays what was what
was christmas like
at the rainy household i imagine you
were a colored light family
well we wear colored lights yeah but
christmas was punctuated the big event
on christmas was
some dude i don't know who he was to
this day i don't know but we had to call
him uncle beave
he would show up on christmas day and
get hammered and
this guy would show up on christmas day
and he would show up on my birthday and
he would only take me out and not my
sister to get presents
he would take me to kitty city i could
spend thirty dollars and then he would
take me
to town like i don't have any memories
of that but
that would look like man you're buying
your [ __ ] toys
wait mcdonald's french fries black out a
little bit shade he would take me to a
howard johnson's in the middle of
nowhere
what oh bro you got raped by a guy is
that the i think that's the only place
bizarre there's there's no rationale on
christmas you got
christmas and your birthday a guy would
show up and rape you
holy [ __ ] dude what dumb what is
happening
your parents let this happen yeah we're
making 500 a trip that's fine like i
said like i have no recollection of
anything we got to check for five grand
whatever dude we're getting game cast
thanks mike taking one for the team on
this one
wait would you stay the night no it
would just be he would pick me up on my
birthday
we would go to kitty city i would spend
30 dollars and then
i can't remember where it was but i
remember going through like like
hillsides
to this howard johnson's and i would get
um they would i remember that the hot
dog was split down the middle
and they would have a toasted bun i bet
his hot dog was split down in the middle
was there mustard on it does that mean
he was uncircumcising
dude have you talked to your parents
about this at all yeah have you talked
to us there have you
have you talked to the police about this
what the [ __ ]
yeah mike this is i didn't know this
yeah holy [ __ ] you said he was a good
guy
i thought i thought this was gonna be a
fun life people out there crying in the
audience
we got a [ __ ] audience full of people
here you know there's gonna be a lot of
like percocet stories and instead of
well there's those two yeah someone's
asking you what your wawa order is yeah
it's like
i treat the whole squad to kid rock
tickets my parents treat the whole squad
to me
yeah that's well they rocked the kid
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] so finish the story so you'd
go to the howard johnson's and what
would you would you go to a room
no it was just it was a restaurant it
wasn't like uh
i tell you what howard johnson's food
was pretty good to be honest with you
yeah
but like i said nobody's getting bored
with that don't act like you guys
haven't been raped in a howard johnson's
don't give me that [ __ ]
man it is tough to follow like uh i got
raped as a kid
i was going to ask you if you ever
applied to work at power windows in
siding
local deep cut power winners
what about thanksgiving who would rape
you on thanksgiving
[ __ ] whole neighborhood that dibs on
[ __ ] rainy damn
this kid was like a [ __ ] advent
calendar every [ __ ] day
another door opens and another closes
behind him
dude that's [ __ ] up man yeah i don't
yeah do you address that with your
parents now
like hey by the way who was the guy that
you let [ __ ] take me to the howard
johnson's in the woods
on my birthday probably the first thing
i would ask my parents
when i got home i did i i had a similar
conversation with them about my aunt
and they were just they just shut it
down right off the bat yeah yeah they
went there
that's that's junk i don't know what
that is
we don't even have showers yeah yeah
you're lying yeah you're [ __ ] lying
you know these kids
lying about getting raped all the time
joe paul's like i didn't have my glasses
on
penn state so yeah sorry wow so a very
sex
positive household yeah you were kidding
me i don't know if the term
sex positive is also yeah sex negative
prognosis nick yeah i don't know what we
could lighten the mood with my addiction
issues if you guys want to switch gears
so you were a cutie yeah that's the one
thing we know
mike rainey was a [ __ ] tight piece of
ass back in the day
you're a cutie yeah don't mean to brag
wow yeah
bro you all right i'm just worried about
everybody else
i think we're all worried about you what
the [ __ ] hey
and when did you start getting into the
pills uh 2012 i had back surgery
yeah [ __ ] uncle b broke it
the [ __ ] out
[Laughter]
you got a little you got a flip and fall
against howard johnson's if you want it
uncle beef blew your back out you got
addicted to the
creepiest name oh man
holy [ __ ] yeah so 2012 i got addicted to
perks
and i got off them in august of 2014.
nice yes
come on guys how about a win tonight we
got one
well we put some percocet in your water
just back on the horse thank you
what do you got give me um one other
thing i want to add and uh
i'm still waiting on the power windows
[Music]
in winter of 2013 i overdosed on
children's painkillers
they give kids painkillers in a bottle
it's liquid that's liquid painkillers
you drank liquid painkillers yes
wait hold on first of all i don't think
there's anything remotely called
children's painkillers i think that's
just painkillers
what they have a balloon on the end of
them or something like that came with
[Laughter]
jesus christ kareem wrote an op-ed
i assume this is our last show ladies
and gentlemen
is there any attorneys in the audience
if there's not there's eight billion big
[ __ ] billboards above us that we can
pick from
you should have called one when you were
getting raped as a kid get somebody to
[ __ ] represent you
i had
actual happening having sex with a guy
yeah we're not saying that actually
yeah no no no we're saying that
absolutely
he was a straight shooter yeah
[Laughter]
yeah right on your face
[Laughter]
so beave was actually the band you're
telling us we got this wrong beef was
genuinely the [ __ ] man like i said i
have no bad memories of beef
beef rules yeah i'm actually starting to
be on
beef he's taking out he's buying toys
taking you to howard johnson
and being like yo jump on the bed it
will be cool if like when b was about to
put on my butt he's like no hojo
was there any mummer's affiliation in
your family you seem like a mother's car
oh
dusty ever froggy car or something
no but um my mother's side of the family
is from south philly they're very digo
heavy
yeah okay yeah all right and like i'm
very irish looking at one point my aunt
pat
like outfitted me in a um the italian
horn that we wear around your neck
so i was very irish overweight and had
an italian horn hanging from
that's the way uncle beave liked you
[Laughter]
get to pick the outfit he's got a little
bummer's costume on him howard johnson
playing the [ __ ] banjo
let's make some noise in here yeah it's
like oh no
all right like i'm always leaning into
it you're getting fully after dark for
some [ __ ] reason
he's typically like jesus oh they're
wacky
[Laughter]
i was like yeah what were you wearing at
the howard johnson well i figured we're
canceled anyway why not have a little
fun with it you know what i mean
and foley looks every bit of the guy
that breathes heavy in the background of
child porn
yeah i said he's dressed like newman
from [ __ ] jurassic park
in here we got datsun now have him go to
the top bunk
you'd look like uncle beast do i look
like i'm
envisioning uncle b you don't not look
like an uncle i'll tell you that much i
apologize
you would end up in a lineup of uncle
biebs for sure
yeah a backwards hat you look like
you're like looks like going undercover
at a middle school
hey kids i'm your age all right
okay all right sorry we'll talk about
kids do you have any tattoos rainy
uh yeah i have a uh
[Music]
yeah you're pretty cut dude so this this
is the name of my favorite corn album
which is life is peachy
[Music]
and on this side is a chimp with my
wife's name underneath a chin
oh what the [ __ ] is that did you get
them at the same time
no um this this one i got right before
my shift working as an orderly at the
hospital
and i went in and like we had orderly
[ __ ] story backstory for sure
dude orderly is the best man or at least
it's like dead guys and [ __ ] it's
awesome have you ever smothered anybody
with a pillow
no no i it's that's a yes by the way
yeah yeah right there you see
it's slow to answer that one that was
something yeah yeah you got to think
about it for a second smothered no
not smoking yeah did you ever kill
anybody with a bill they got out they
got out you think they're
you think they're weak but they got a
little fight in them some people are
already on their way
just helps him yeah you got to like talk
to him you know you give him like
negative
like die die it starts like talking
gibberish like jonathan davis
um let's fast forward a little i got one
out there all right let's fast forward
let's talk about your house now i got a
question about your house now
what is currently on the top of your
refrigerator in your home now
uh papers what
like paperwork you keep your paperwork
on top of the fridge
yeah yeah i don't know why it goes up
there what paperwork what do you got
going on papers you get hurt warren
buffett does the same thing
you get papers you put them somewhere
elon musk keeps them in the freezer so i
don't feel bad
let's put these babies on ice wow all
right i was looking for paperwork i
think
oh and an answer would be cereal
at my parents house is just like a
shearer for my cat
a what like a thing that cut the cat's
hair it was for like cattle
or like how big is the cat yeah the
cat's but
now we use it for the cat we shorn the
cat sure dude you are like [ __ ]
that's the hillbilliest pennsylvania of
country trash
it's nice the cat likes who shears their
own cat tibble the cat
shout out temple shout out the prince of
cats
shakespearean these billy lights are
getting in me come on now
i miss that [ __ ] cat dude how many of
you guys just started crying about a
sheer dead cat
but he left me five grand so it was
pretty cool man
kevin all right you keep going to me you
haven't asked the [ __ ] question yet
what do you mean i got the beef story
out of it
on [ __ ] coke what's happening this
guy's bonkos
so you have kids now right yeah i got
three kids you have three kids how much
porn do you watch with them
how's that reaganomics that trickle-down
effect treating your kids
so obviously you you do things
differently i hope
yeah no porn we really limit screen
time okay that's good yeah
you seem like you really turned around
how old are you right now how old am i
yeah
41. yeah you seem like you really
[ __ ] you really made a pivot i feel
yeah with the past few years i kind of
got my [ __ ] together and um
yeah what's your wife know any of this
or she hearing this for the first time
yeah she's there
she knows she knows it all so she's not
just about
awesome growing up in car ride home if
your wife didn't know about [ __ ]
uncle beave and aunt bitty
her first question so where's the rest
of this five grand yeah
now and i give her a lot of credit too
because without her i would still be a
degenerate so
oh give it up for mrs rainey everybody
look at that dude talk about a kid
getting [ __ ] turning it around
and honestly we're joking around but
this is what the podcast is all about
you know
it is about you know having you know
dramatic things or [ __ ] get sincere
bully everybody
i'm trying to [ __ ] cover our tracks
shut the [ __ ] up
what are you talking about so what's
going on guys this is actually what it's
all
about you know shut the [ __ ] up just a
couple of guys
shot fully you've been laughing at a guy
who got raped as a kid
for an hour and you're like hey you know
at the end it turns around
that's what you know i knew it was
turning around it's really a life lesson
folks just so you know that it's really
a life lesson here on are you garbage
you stink so do you guys do color lights
now or you do white lights
uh it's a mixture of babies it's so
weird to try to pivot out of what we do
actually i was going to ask you if
there's you've ever put fly paper in
your house
why paper yeah there's some hanging in
the basement doorway
really yeah how long has it been there
is it is it doused up
uh your kids is in it it's more of a
warning to other flies
what about a bug zapper do you have an
electric bug no we haven't upgraded yet
where do you live now
uh right by the airport cargo city nice
oh my goodness i thought we were going
to turn a corner here
how are johnson's by the airport i don't
know why i just wasn't
like i have to live near howard
johnson's i don't know what it is i get
a cozy feeling every time i see the
light
ah all right okay how loud is that by
the way
it's fine
after a couple of 7 47 i don't even
notice it i think honestly
subconsciously i might have chosen it
because you know as a kid one of my
uh one of my worst memories was of
hearing my parents have sex all the time
jesus
so it's like the more that i i guess
maybe subconsciously i chose to live
near the airport yeah get that jet
engine
yeah to hide your mode yeah really
[ __ ] numb your brain dude and i
actually i actually heard a whisper
argument
with my between my mom and dad my dad
was trying to get my mom to suck his
dick
and she was standing in her ground and
she was not having it and i gave him a
lot of credit for maintaining the
whisper the entire time
what was he saying suck it in that suck
it what
yeah how else do you ask a woman to suck
your dick with you frank with your
family who the [ __ ] knows
pardon me maybe get a tape off your
sister see what happens i don't [ __ ]
know
i'm surprised there's a question mark at
the end of it yeah
suck your dick in your family what's
that the answer is like
what do you want some candy
[Laughter]
in my uh
by and large like my parents have a good
relationship although there was one
moment
there was one moment where my dad
actually threatened my mom with a knife
at the dinner table
butter or steak it was a steak night
okay well how well how well done was the
steak
we were we were having hungry mans that
night
that's the thing it was a one-and-done
deal so damn can you witness this
yeah he he i don't know i forget what
was going on right in the [ __ ]
picked it up and he extended his arm
then he dropped it now i'm getting ahead
tonight
done with this bickering that was the
only time that ever happened like it was
never
a thing that occurred on a regular basis
so i'm inclined to think it was
something my mom said
sure it's okay
victim blaming okay i like it have you
ever been to myrtle beach
[Laughter]
funny you should ask i actually got
[ __ ] in the ass down in myrtle beach
i actually killed a hooker in myrtle
beach we actually spread my aunt's ashes
there
she loved the strip clubs that one
[Laughter]
really have you ever been to my myrtle
beach or ocean city maryland williams
williamsburg
uh colonial williamsburg where'd you get
what was a rainy fame
rainy family vacation oh dude wildwood
wildwood what street were you looking at
uh rio grande i think not the good part
okay
rio grande sounds pretty classy no it is
not
it's like wellington road it ain't dude
when we would get the wildwood my dad
would give me a 10
roll of quarters to go to the arcade
while him and my mom banged it out what
the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is going on with
the rainies they love each other how hot
is your mom
dude she had a fat ass before fat asses
were cool
really yup that's
[Laughter]
all right what about this growing up did
you have milk with dinner
no soda soda yes yeah [ __ ] garbage
[Music]
my round of applause who drank milk
within a round of applause
yeah the milkman unite that's about 50
let's go guy guy who got a 12 something
on his sats
milk exactly yeah that's why he did so
good give it up for my man back there
yeah you're all [ __ ] nerds dude what
are you talking about
jacked nerds
do you still do you still do you still
drink milk with dinner
when i'm home i crush milk like to this
day i
i caught myself what are we doing whole
whole 2 percent one percent come on man
i'm worried about my figure but
[Laughter]
i caught myself like cutting the lawn
and coming inside
and drinking milk because it was like
hot out and i was like oh i gotta cool
off
dude i'm telling you it's [ __ ] none
of you would last in my world dude
you would have crumbled by now
[Laughter]
all right mike have you ever the next
time magazine he's gonna have a milk
mustache on the cover
kind of soften the blow a little bit
have you or anything
uncle bev beef had a milk mustache of
childhood five minutes passed unclean
come on come
on oh child to come is my favorite john
steinbeck
[Laughter]
more of a giving tree kind of kid i'd
assume have you or any member of your
family ever lived
near or connected to a cemetery
no all right shocker i don't think
that's going to pull you out of the fire
but okay
no but i'm sure i was [ __ ] you're
really going to need to [ __ ] rally
out of this one rainy
do you sleep with a fan directly on you
sometimes yes
okay yeah how many pillows do you use
when you sleep
uh there's like six holy [ __ ] just so
you guys know the more pillows
[Laughter]
builds a chastity wall
have you ever owned or anybody in your
family ever owned a ford ranger or a
dodge neon
neon yes that's no bueno
have you ever owned a beaded curtain to
divide rooms in a home
that's what i wanted you to talk about
all right that's a story
well back when uncle b would come over
all right when he heard the beads
[ __ ] jingle
all right so what is it all right so i
have not had a beaded curtain in my home
however
when i was getting ready to leave for
boot camp there was a very kind women
woman who let me eat her box and
i shout out to her and how [ __ ] up
that's how you support the troops
he came up to me i haven't seen him and
i haven't seen him in years he came out
hey what's up how you doing we had like
this great adult conference like
normal that level had a conversation
wild rainy is like the sweetest
nicest oh dude most like supportive
friend
you could ever have he's literally the
best so
you know it makes a little sense now i
hear how [ __ ] damaged
like like every once i'll be like life's
great dude i'll do anything for anybody
yeah i'm like
back to this back to you eating this
chicks explosive right before 9 11.
yep that's what inspired me to become a
troop
[Laughter]
for her i can do this for the country
but i was terrified of women so this is
the only sexual experience i had and i
was like 19.
so the night before i left for boot camp
i went to spencer's gifts
and i i bought her and her best friend
uh glow-in-the-dark beaded curtains
for what i'm a gentleman
[Laughter]
you don't gift women after they let you
eat their box you [ __ ] weirdo
he shows up on top i had a [ __ ] gift
card to spencer so
i got you a blacklight poster and some
beads
anyway off to iraq
i hope this finds you well dearest
martha
dear uncle beef the terrorists are
trying to stop us
i give her a family guy hoodie with my
scent on it so she can have me when i'm
away
[Laughter]
do you currently have any collection of
knives at your home yes
yeah butterfly you got a butterfly you
got a switchblade what are you working
with uh butterfly knife yeah yeah any
num chucks
you know do you know how to hold on do
you know how to do tricks with the
butterfly knife no
okay is that it
yeah i'm sorry what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] him jerkle do you own a samurai
sword
no i do not i would like one is that it
that's what we're working for that's the
goal have any of your houses ever had
carpet in the bathroom
no no okay an aristocrat do you
currently own the cooking device known
as
a wok i do not okay did you hear a set
have you ever had a beaded seat cover in
your car i have not
he might he's making a rally i'll give
him that
does anybody in your family have a
tattoo of a country's flag on them
no but my sister has a philadelphia soul
tattoo oh
no no wow no
that dude this is crazy this is the
worst piece she got in early she's like
this is gonna be the next big [ __ ]
thing
she's gotta film bon jovi was like i'm
[ __ ] out of here later
yeah it's right on her ankle what a
ankle philadelphia assault
yep is this the same sister that got
shot yes
dude they could take her life but they
can't take her philadelphia
yeah they got the barnstormers next week
the binghamton
the rink rats are coming into town i
heard
is the trash can in your home underneath
the cabinet below the sink
no it's next to the um to the cabinets
next to the cab all right that's pretty
classy i like that is it trashy to have
it under
yeah that's real trashy really i feel
like it's hidden no that's because it's
always smaller and it's always full and
it stinks and it's [ __ ] garbage
do you want to pull out couch
uh it reclines is there uh
your couch reclines the whole cloud
that's a small [ __ ] couch
it's a futon
what the [ __ ] are you talking about come
on man come on man
here's one the big one on are you
garbage these days do you brush your
teeth
yeah in the shop
i'm not a [ __ ] animal dude take it
easy let me finish the question
but not in the shower no i i brush them
over the sink like like a [ __ ]
gentleman
shower's the move shower is the [ __ ]
rules
shower actually rules a lot of you
thinking it doesn't roll it rules it
does not fall where's my
where's my shower she's out there make
some [ __ ] noise
guy that got good sats where you brush
your teeth
dude there's some animals out there like
flossing and [ __ ] in the shower i floss
not in the shower no you don't you don't
just start flossing dude
what what'd you say [ __ ] don't get
[ __ ] up here
don't get knocked out in this parking
lot dude all right
radio [ __ ] you up dude i'll unleash my
rapey friend
as long as i'm not currently getting
[ __ ] i will [ __ ] you up
all right we have some listeners we have
some questions from the from the live
audience
oh people have written in um wait hold
on how's this going so far you guys
having a good time
all right no one ever speaks of this
again
yeah that's definitely going behind a
paywall for sure it's a real uncle beef
episode
don't tell anybody about it this is our
secret
if you guys tell anybody about this
episode we're going to kill your parents
[Laughter]
rainey's going to go into work i'm going
to be what'd you do i got nothing i
didn't do [ __ ] [ __ ] this weekend dude
yeah true ready very loyal keeps his
mouth shut that's right
to his adult lovers this is for this is
for both this will be
this will be for shane and for rainy uh
this is from day
uh davey have you ever taken a koozie to
a bar
i feel like you might have shane yeah i
swear to g i
must have accidentally like a notre dame
couple probably a dozen times
yes that's [ __ ] does anybody have a
koozie on them right now
kyla brought a koozie to helium last
night what's the point
i don't know i don't know dude i'm just
picturing kyla pronouncing the word
koozie i guarantee her jaw dislocates
[Laughter]
dan setter sounds like jacuzzi
yeah it does it almost does good
all right this is from pat have you ever
participated in the mating of a dog or a
cat
wow cool i feel you you were talking
about your cat
i love my cat but i would never ever
uncle beaver
no not you [ __ ] them you idiot have
you like tried to mate two dogs or
two cats no well i know rainey grew up
in a very sexy i don't know
i'm afraid to hear rainey's answer here
uh i didn't encourage it but i didn't
stop it either
did it produce a litter yeah yeah really
really what was dogs or cats it was cats
oh you watched cats [ __ ]
yeah why is that worse you got any taste
that's the weirdest thing we've heard
all night we filmed it then my dad asked
we had tapes of the video
oh mike no no all right well what the
[ __ ]
yeah unfortunately that sounds
believable coming out of your mouth
uh this is from phil have you ever put
ketchup on a steak
yeah yeah yeah do you do that
like a cheese steak or like a proper
like like oh that is so trash though
that's where your head goes when we say
steak yeah
we mean like a gino's or a pack you mean
a burger you're talking about a burger
i don't know yes i put ketchup on my
steak you
defunded sorry what you like talking to
my friend back there
actually like a [ __ ] jerk what you
put ketchup on a steak
i put it on pizza sometimes what
yeah just so you [ __ ] freak snow
[Laughter]
that's real mechanics it's actually gone
it's actually good
no it's not dude you'd be surprised you
put everybody's looking at like you like
you probably
don't go right now i promise it is not
you sound like somebody advocating child
sex
trust me try it it's good just give it
one try first off guarantee it feels
good
the ketchup how do you get your steak
cooked i i'm curious about that
me and my all right rainy well
well yeah dude you are a psycho he is
man
sorry about that feels good joke i was
uh
having fun i got carried away there
but we're all adults we can uh all right
this is for uh
this is from mike how often did you eat
shake and bake as a kid
uh at least once a week wow we would
have pork chops pretty often
pork chop shake and bake yeah is that a
thing that [ __ ] rules yeah
like the bottom gets soggy a little ah i
love so good that's the best yeah
we were a big hamburger helper dude
like i'm surprised you picked me as a
french cuisine you know hamburger helper
holds up
straight you guys have that lately
hamburger helpers
somebody has that chick has had
hamburger help her recently
nine hands just went up for lunch
jesus christ all right we only got a
couple of minutes left here this is from
ryan has anyone in your family
and uncle or cousin ever had a pickup
truck with a spoiler on it
no what was your first car no
um i just remember being like like a
[ __ ]
boat i don't remember what's in the
priest's class
you blocked out a lot of your child man
that is not a [ __ ] good sign
his life started when he was 22. that's
when i woke up
man that's cool you can make kids time
travel
you can [ __ ] them into their 30s
see that's going to be big part 2.
here's our howard johnson sponsor
shout out to hojo come on barcelo
here all right this is from trey have
you ever peed in a bottle to avoid
walking to the bathroom at home
at home no but um i just had a girl in
the audience go [ __ ] yeah
my wife has a pretty good accuracy right
there i'll tell you that
but the last time i peed in the bottom
my wife was driving me to one of my
favorite murder sites
which is the sharon tate house in los
angeles
yeah that get that gets a woo and i was
picking a family
and why do you have a favorite murder
site why doesn't he what are you
talking about what's your second
favorite one
uh the second night of the murders of
the maine
yeah that actually makes sense too
because i remember you always going to
la and being like
the [ __ ] manson [ __ ] and i was
always like oh that's the only way he
can
feel anymore once you check out
disneyland like a [ __ ] normal person
but now it makes sense
the guy that ended up buying sharon
tate's old house he demolished the house
and he put up this monstrosity but it's
the executive producer of full house
[Music]
[Laughter]
you're definitely going to break into
the family matters house and kill that
guy
i didn't say probably matters i said
full house whatever so you think carl
winslow's in there
do you get omaha steaks at your house
before i answer that
if urkel committed the murder do you
think you'd be like did i do that
but omaha steaks we got them one time
they came door to door
and we it was the one i don't think that
was omaha's things
he got tricked yeah dude omaha steaks
does not come door-to-door
we had lincoln there's a catalog like a
[ __ ] north dakota beef that's what
that was
i've never heard of it
hamburger albert milk you guys are
telling me that's not a good night
please i love shane five miller lights
deep
he starts scrambling i'll tell you
what's going on here
all right we only got a couple of
minutes then we gotta get out of here um
i got one or two more have you ever paid
to have anything airbrushed
yes i am his [ __ ] definitely
yes in 1996
[Laughter]
on the ocean city boardwalk i had an
airbrushed t-shirt that said wu tank the
wu-tang symbol on the front
uh because i was a big wigger and then
on the back it said my name in cursive
but i overheard kids talking about how
they were going to rob me for the shirt
so i took it off and threw it out it was
cursed
as it was a cursed shirt a gypsy at the
boardwalk put a hex on your wu tang
all right i got one more does anyone in
your family pronounce the days of the
week as monday
tuesday wednesday everybody everybody
yeah that's a real dirtbag [ __ ]
[Laughter]
ladies and gentlemen mr mike [ __ ]
rainy thank you guys
we'll take this one to the audience by
round of applause
who thinks mike rainey is class
[Laughter]
i think that was his wife that was it
and who thinks mike rainey is total
garbage
ladies and gentlemen this has been the
first live edition of ru garbage
we want to thank you guys honestly so
much for supporting the podcast
give me a nice big round of applause for
mr shane gillis
give me a nice big round of applause for
my co-host kippy kevin james ryan
and give me a nice big round of applause
for the punchline of philadelphia for
having us here tonight
give me a nice big round of applause for
mr mike [ __ ] raining
and give yourself a nice big round of
applause philadelphia we love you guys
let's hang out out front peace goodnight
everybody